questions over who's in charge of
america's foreign policy china ramping
up pressure and threats after nancy
pelosi's controversial visit to taiwan
beijing suspending all military and
climate talks with the u.s over the
speaker's visit at the same time the
chinese military continuing its massive
military drills sending taiwan's air
force scrambling as dozens of chinese
fighter jets and warships closed in on
the island now critics say biden's
looking weak for postponing a scheduled
missile test in the south china sea the
bite administration has been trying to
ratchet down the tensions but nancy
pelosi is putting her foot down when it
comes to taiwan
we have said from the start
that our representation here is not
about changing the status quo our
friendship with taiwan is a strong one
it is bipartisan in the house and the
senate
overwhelming support
for peace
and the status quo
in taiwan
and secretary of state anthony blinken
is sounding the alarm over china's
escalation of force
these provocative actions
are a significant escalation the fact is
the speaker's visit was peaceful
there is no justification
for this extreme
disproportionate
and escalatory military response
all right so judge is this china debacle
under president biden does it appear
that it's getting even worse now i i
don't think there's any doubt about it i
mean you know what you think about
what's going on in the world we've got
we just took down al uh zawahiri
we've got uh the taliban has reclaimed
afghanistan there's a war in ukraine
russia is starting to join with china on
various issues and nancy pelosi is the
speaker of the house she is the speaker
of the house the house is in the united
states she is a legislator that is her
job now my understanding is that the
president didn't want her to go that the
white house wasn't in favor of this so
why they didn't put an end to it i don't
know but what we've got is china now
cozying up to russia at a time when we
didn't need this why nancy is doing this
maybe she's not going to be speaker in a
few months maybe she knows it and you
know this is just for her timetable and
this whole idea as i've said i'll say it
again if we don't speak out for human
rights in china we lose all moral
authority you know i mean what is she in
taiwan for just to continue with the one
china policy i think it's a dangerous
time to be doing that so joey if she's
there in taiwan putting her foot down
against the white house's
wanting her to go and do this
if truly we are seeing president biden
take a back seat it leaves us wondering
who's in charge of foreign policy for
this country if not the president the
story here for me the whole time has
been this dynamic between the
administration and nancy pelosi who
who's making decisions who's the leader
of the democratic party who's the leader
of the agenda of the party that is
ruling our country i mean a lot of us
feel like looking at joe biden in
history and joe biden now he's being led
by the more progressives in his party uh
even some of his supporters have said
henry cuellar said that he's surrounded
by people that don't hold actually joe
biden's view and are influencing him
when he was talking about the border so
my concern is
not just like who's running our country
like hey joe biden's not calling the
shots but
you know what is joe biden taking into
account when he doesn't stop nancy
pelosi from going if it is he believes
that's not a good thing to do right now
which i don't understand why it was this
is a fight we're gonna have to have i
mean literally eisenhower was handling
the taiwan straight crisis right so this
has never gone away
our policy for decades has been and
you've seen it on tv this week to say we
acknowledge the one china policy which
my understanding it had something to do
with taiwan's original claim to still be
the legitimate government of china and
has evolved into this one china policy
which is china's claim over taiwan so we
have a government that talks out both
sides of its mouse on this issue hoping
to pacify and kick the can down the road
that fight's going to happen sometime
and when i say fight i don't mean war i
mean coming to terms with it and if
china feels empowered to do something
about it now or if they feel desperate
to show their power to do something
about it now
i feel like that's going to happen this
just probably isn't the administration i
want in charge when it happens i'm sorry
and i i rarely disagree with y'all and i
love y'all to death but this is not an
issue of policy
it's a issue of proportion response to
what nancy pelosi i disagree with on
this i don't think we should be involved
in these affairs
but try to send a delegation too they
sent a delegation of people with covet
killed our elderly right right they hid
it from the world many people died as a
result of that and then they want to
have war gains they want to do missiles
as a response to nancy pelosi having a
conversation and a photo walk with some
old people we let them get away with
copenhagen what do you expect the bottom
line is this whether i agree with nancy
pelosi or not yeah the speaker of the
house is a co-equal branch she doesn't
take her marching orders from joe biden
if she wanted to go there that's on here
the fact is that they feel comfortable
telling them they're going to shoot down
the pain the plane of the person that is
third line of succession i think that's
bs and i'm sorry i think it's
anti-american uh um not to stand
with the speaker of the house when
they're threatening her like that i i
just i i just i just i think it's
dangerous to america to not be lock and
step with the speaker of the house when
she's doing this that's the problem i'm
not really taking a position because i
don't know if it were better or worse
for her to go i know that sitting here
is an american seeing our president
speaker of the house being on two
different pages with what is probably
our biggest enemy that scares the hell
out of me i think we we have to separate
the policy which i agree with you on and
the fact that the threats that china is
doing are on american citizens and the
president has zero response to it zero
defense of nancy pelosi zero defense of
the country so if this is indeed
significant escalation as secretary
blinken suggested how should the
president be responding jessica i guess
he should be saying that he will match
whatever he has to to ensure that taiwan
gets to keep its independence he did
have that little gaffe where he said
that you know we would intervene in the
same way that we did ukraine obviously
it's a very separate kind of issue and
we will not be sending troops
to taiwan um but what's really important
here is that nancy pelosi is doing what
dozens of legislators have done before
there's there are congressional
delegations in taiwan constantly you saw
45 republicans signed that letter in
support of her the biden administration
overstepped by getting involved in her
plans and potentially leaking the
details of this because nancy pelosi
regularly pops up in places because her
security matters you are not supposed to
telegraph the fact that the person who's
third in line for the presidency is
going to be showing up somewhere let
alone somewhere like taiwan so that's
incredibly dangerous whoever did that i
know senator cotton um came on our
network and said explicitly that it was
the biden administration that hasn't
been confirmed um he didn't want it it
obviously rocks the vote and you have
knew that there would be a retaliation
from china here but this is no reason
for us to turn our backs on decades of
support of taiwan or of nancy pelosi who
is an incredible figure in our
government and representative of our
values and how much it meant to the
taiwanese taiwanese people as well you
saw that reception that she got there
that kind of support matters when they
live in the shadows of what managing
matters too and to send mixtures i think
her messaging was perfect i think that
the binding administration's messaging
was
far from perfect and that this is on
them versus the speaker a hundred well
the speaker needs to call out the
president of the united states and as
you as you what is her life is on the
line okay
so she could and we're so grateful for
that but as as we started off the show
today about the partisan politics of
this she could have told joe biden back
me up you said you've been my friend for
all these years they've threatened my
life what are you going to do about it
you have to do that
back then he sent his representatives
out there to say that he's not in charge
of the speaker's schedule we'll just
never forget john kirby last week asking
what's all the drama
okay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else